Every time a cell divides, all the chromosomes line up at the center. All the
duplicated chromosomes. Then they separate. They split
up equally into the daughter cells. We can
imagine these chromosomes being pulled apart here
form the center and one piece One side
going to either daughter cell. Now if something
goes wrong, and one chromosome doesn't separate correctly,
And so both chromatids end up going to one
daughter cell. So if one side gets one more chromosome
and one side gets one less chromosome, this is called
Aneuploidy. Obviously this can cause major problems. But imagine what
a big deal this would be if it happened in
one of your germ cells. And one of your gametes
ended up with more or less chromosomes. So that when
it fertilized an opposite sex gamete, you produced a whole
offspring, a whole child, another human. With
one more or less chromosome. So let's make
sure you're where I want you to be
with information about chromosomes. Tell me which of
the following are examples of aneuploidy. 46 chromosomes
total, 47 chromosomes total, 3 of chromosome 21.
45 chromosomes total, 1 X chromosome and no
Y. 47 chromosomes total, 2 x chromosomes, and
1 y. Go ahead and pick any and all answers that you think apply.